bueno
pues hoy nos hemos despertado con la noticia de que el
rey de marruecos
está muy contento con el giro político
dado por pedro sánchez
en materia de política exterior
está muy satisfecho de que españa haya traicionado
al pueblo saharaui
está muy satisfecho
del trabajo que se está revisando las fronteras
vulnerando todos los derechos humanos
y está muy satisfecho de que en canarias
haya subido un 25
el flujo migratorio
aplaudiendo la actitud del señor pedro sánchez
insisto
vendiendo canarias y vendiendo al pueblo saharaui
muy mal tiene que ir la cosa
cuando el único
que está satisfecho
con la política migratoria de españa
es el reino de marruecos